bonjour jacques naisy merci de répondre
à nos questions démission cet après-midi
de l'émissaire américain en haïti ils
dénoncent les expulsions je cite
inhumaines de migrants quelles
conséquences cette démission peut-elle
avoir à ce que ça peut inciter joe biden
à agir davantage
je possède décision peut avoir double
effet le premier fai et bus et le
désengagement quasiment des états unis
d'amérique par rapport à la politique
haïtien de cet avenir que haïti traverse
une crise politique assez longue bien
avant et d'avant l'assassinât du jeune
moïse et que la mission de cet envoyé
spécial était d'apaiser la situation et
de trouver une issue favorable à travers
un compromis entre les crocs la
différence forces partisanes et la
société civile en haïti mais psa
démissionnait pas ne s'explique pas
seulement par la chronique gâteau elle
s'explique aussi par la difficulté de
monsieur foot dans sa mission avec
l'ambassade l'ambassadrice américaine en
haïti qui elle est considérée comme
éteinte au concile qui agit qui qui agit
en de façon pleine et entière
c'est-à-dire comme étant comme étant la
présidente de l'état haïtien alors on
voit bien qu'il s'agit de conflits sans
doute que d'asnières foot n'avait pas de
rapport de force que daniel fou a perdu
avec l'ambassadrice américaine
maintenant pour revenir à la crise
migratoire haïtienne il faut dire que
cette vieux serpent de mer la question
migratoire
haïtienne ça toujours marqué les
relations bilatérales entre haïti et les
états unis d'avion parce que les fleurs
glissant quelles sont les relations
entre les états unis et haïti
ces relations qui remonte au 19ème
siècle quand haïti d'ailleurs a eu son
indépendance en 1804 d'ailleurs haïti a
même participé à l'indépendance
américaine qu'en haïti fut appelée saint
domaine en envoyant des généraux
militaires à sabra d'arrêt puis en 1858
y en a eu des relations militaires avec
les états unis d'amérique puis sur 1812
pétion avait même envoyé 150 soldats
avec un sourire les états unis
d'amérique à consolider leur
indépendance et dire qu'il y a des
relations lointaine et qu par la suite
en 1900 caisses des états unis d'abord
souhaité montrer que l'amérique et s'y
est donc l'arrière coût des états unis
d'amérique et ils ont inventé cette
doctrine ce petit de mondo la merco
américaines sont intervenus en haïti en
1915 mais avant ils sont intervenus dans
les zones dans l'est dans les mers
haïtienne 15 fois au 18e siècle et puis
en en 1994 les états unis sont
intervenus à la frontière
américano-mexicaine ça veut dire que
tout ce que vous énumérez là ça tombe
bien
on ne sait pas oublié ce coup souligné
que qui que la migration haïtienne aux
états unis d'amérique à tvo est et a
toujours été une politique a toujours
marqué les relations bilatérales entre
les états d'ailleurs comme bill clinton
est intervenue en haïti en 1994 est l'un
des objectifs de sa mission était dire
que de deux dindes idée le flux des
nigauds qui pourraient envahir les états
unis d'amérique donc mais il faut le
remarquer aussi 7 c'est l'échec de la
politique américaine vis-à-vis d'haïti
c'est à dire que les états une amie
pneus se sont ne jamais engagé un plan
de reconstruction économique d'haïti ces
artisans investi à travers les saïd et
des aides on veut dire sous forme de
saupoudrage médias pas un projet phare
qui permettent aux haïtiens de vivre de
façon décente en haïti et de renoncer à
tout projet de limiter aux états unis et
comment est ce que la politique
migratoire l'adagio byetone elle est
perçue en haïti en ce moment il ya les
arrêts les haïtiens procès que dieu
byden allait rompre avec la politique de
son prédécesseur donald toi puisque tu
vas eden avait rencontré la communauté
haïtienne lors de sa campagne électorale
e ou
s'engager pour faire des promesses
certes il ya eu il a délivré il a
octroyé le titre de résidence provisoire
le tps à certains haïtiens nme mais il y
en a d'autres qui ont conseillé comme
étant un appel d'air et donc tous ceux
qui étaient au chili quitter et au
brésil que vendu armes et bagages et
sont donc en tout cas aux états unis
pensa que la politique de ben laden
allait être plus humaine à le regarder
il se sent trompé du suivi se sont rendu
compte
et quelle solution alors selon vous à la
fois pour que la situation se décante à
la frontière entre les états unis
mexique mais aussi pour que la situation
s'améliore pour les initiants en haïti
où perdure insécurité l'instabilité
politique la célébrité après les
récentes catastrophes naturelles pourra
grand séisme oui la première solution
qu'on pourrait envisager c'était d'un
visage moratoire c'est à dire d'examiner
au cas par cas certaines situations et
de voir deux aussi d'appliquer un
traitement humer à ces migrants haïtiens
et de voir de quelle mesure on pourrait
accorder à certains d'entre eux le titre
de résidence de serait ne serait que
résidait provisoire et puis en même
temps de travailler avec les partenaires
haïtiens locaux de trouver une solution
à ce prix là vous le remarquez c'est une
pluie sma et
l'absence le désengagement total en
termes d'investissements et puis la
chute non seulement la fuite des
cerveaux et mais la fuite des
investisseurs parce que la situation
haïtienne aujourd'hui elle est naples
puisque ce sont des gands en meti les
seniors du cas de violences et de toutes
activités et en être surtout plastique
suis tout sur tout le périmètre que de
la capitale surtout de permettre de s m
et 70 départements sont même conseil on
peut se demander pourquoi les états unis
d'abord pas une technique autorités
haïtiennes en vue de servir de ces vies
au procès
loïc deux choses fo était examinée au
cas par cas des situations des deux
leaders demandeur d'asile nous et
ensuite ceux qui auraient ils sont
nombreux ainsi votre et d'autres faire
en sorte que situation politique y
trouvent une solution rapide
ir pas
améliorée par à médiocre de nos
politiques organiser de nouvelles
élections et renforcer les institutions
merci jacques naisy d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
politologue et membre du laboratoire qui
a rivière de sciences sociales vous êtes
spécialiste évidemment d'haïti